el almuerzo de trabajo de este lunes es
una continuación de discusiones previas
sobre defensa economía y energía el
enfoque según París es fortalecer la
cooperación bilateral Unión y
solidaridad frente a los desafíos
actuales desafíos que no son ni pocos ni
superficiales y que han sembrado la
discordia en el matrimonio Franco alemán
entre los platos difíciles de digerir en
este almuerzo de trabajo está la
política energética el presidente de
francés Es partidario de fijar un límite
al precio para la compra de gas en el
mercado mundial shorts se opone a ello
Porque esa estrategia empujaría a los
productores a venderlos fuera de la zona
del euro a mejores postores y si eso
sucede pues se agudiza la escasez otro
hueso duro de roer la inversión de
Alemania en materia militar Berlín ha
dejado a Francia plantada al
comprometerse a importar aviones de
fabricación estadounidense y material
norteamericano e israelí para su
plataforma de defensa antimisiles y
antiaéreas esto a pesar de que París
tiene material propio y son comunes con
la nación germana los vínculos entre
ambos países atraviesan una etapa tan
árida que por primera vez en 20 años se
suspendió el consejo bilateral de
ministros que se realiza anualmente y
estaba previsto precisamente para hoy
otro indicador de las desaveniencias
existentes es que no habrá conferencias
de prensa conjunto como Suele suceder en
este tipo de intercambio con estos
desaires meses de su Unión fortalecer la
columna vertebral de la Unión Europea
como se considera el eje Franco alemán
es una tarea nada fácil para ambos
comensales